we just filmed in the harshest
environment on earth in the Arctic the
temperatures can drop to minus 40
degrees and therefore whole months of
darkness during the year for me
personally to the Arctic is really
important because when you actually get
all the conditions lined up and you're
able to capture in IMAX all the beauty
of incredible sunlight the animal
behavior and the right story attached to
it it's magnificent you really get a
sense of what an incredibly diverse
ecosystem it is up there to the Arctic
is near and dear to me because with the
ice melting the polar bears and the
other animals are undergoing the change
that they're having to get accustomed to
captain's up in the crow's nest 60 feet
up making sure we don't hit any huge
icebergs we've got that the sink to ship
this is one of our more challenging
shoots we spent three weeks aboard a
ship called The Hoff so we basically had
to bring everything we can think of on
board with us in the locations if you
needed something you couldn't get it so
basically you had two of everything in
case one did break down or so let that
you had a backup
we got within just a few degrees of the
north pole it was one of the most
exciting and interesting trips I've ever
been on in my career you know we
actually are going to some pretty
extreme conditions high seas cold
temperatures the water temperatures 20
degrees the deck can get pretty icy and
you may fall overboard
so this is actually very dangerous we're
out here in the middle of no place
surrounded by ice you know I've always
said our job is to put the camera where
it doesn't want to be now we have the
ability to put it in many places it just
couldn't be we want to get in kind of
dangerous positions with that Wow the
audience will give them that wow factor
put you in a position where you wouldn't
be able to go as IMAX filmmakers we get
to go to really cool places and engage
with very compelling wildlife and
occasionally we have to just kind of
stop and appreciate that if you can make
every moment a joy then you're gonna
make a better self
you